I love you guys you're showing I'll are  you quarantine I want to thank the  audience for all of the dick pics from  two weeks ago  your audience is always so generous in  DMing me um  dick pics and you know it's a quarantine  so fill up my inbox everybody oh my  goodness  - Eric sent him one and Eric keeps  emailing me to ask what Andy thought of  his dick did you see the picture Andy I  didn't get that one I'm not even kidding  I didn't see it if I did he sent it to  me I'm not far out to you Oh God how  many dick pics did you get be real I  probably got 60 wow that is amazing you  guys straight guys you know what they  call that they call it a [ __ ] I Vilanch  okay here's know you got Eric's it's  like three pieces of candy under a belly